so you're johnson and johnson in the
1970s you sell the world's most innocent
helpful products to new parents baby
powder it smells nice try some i mean
what could be wrong with baby powder
soft smooth powder that keeps babies dry
comfortable and clean and even better
johnson enjoying baby powder isn't just
good for babies it's also good for
adults what more could you ask for
by the early 70s you've been making your
signature baby powder for nearly 80
years and it's become a staple to nearly
every family in america but then you run
into an unexpected problem you see your
researchers have just discovered
something shocking something that might
mean the end to your powerful profitable
baby powder monopoly
there is poison in the baby powder
poison in the form of asbestos a toxic
mineral found in one of the ingredients
talc talc is what makes the powder so
soft and smooth and even though there's
only a little bit of asbestos in each
bottle of your baby powder even small
amounts can become incredibly dangerous
over time asbestos is so bad for humans
it doesn't just make people sick it can
even lead to cancer
now obviously finding especially in your
best-selling product gear towards
infants is a major problem but let's
face it without tack the ingredient that
has asbestos your baby powder would suck
it wouldn't have that signature johnson
and josten smoothness and without your
number one family friendly products your
image as a family-friendly company would
be destroyed
if you admitted your baby powder was
toxic no parent in their right mind
would ever trust any of your other
products again you would have to lose a
bunch of money in time to recalls and
you'll probably face some legal action
you would be done
so instead of saying something instead
of warning your loyal customers that
they're poisoning their infants you do
nothing you don't raise any alarms you
arrange for any more testing you just
shove the reports into the deepest
darkest corner you can find and pray
nothing ever comes out
but like most companies that keep
secrets the truth eventually comes back
to haunt you only this time the public's
discovery of especials in your baby
powder wouldn't just be another
short-lived scandal they knew about it
they knew there was asbestos in johnson
and johnson baby powder it would expose
all your shittiest marketing tactics and
lies and showed the world just how evil
america's most family-friendly company
really is may have known for decades
imagine the level of harm
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is
a giant game of acquiring power you
can't get out of this game either way so
instead of being a victim why not learn
to be a better player
your parents teachers friends society
will never teach you any of this so
we're going to
and this is johnson and johnson
america's evilest family company
[Music]
smart crypto investors are buying the
dip right now but if you do the same you
want to make sure you don't waste a ton
of money on super high transaction fees
and luckily that is where binance comes
in binance is the largest crypto
exchange in the world by daily trading
volume and now you get to trade bitcoin
on binance for free that's right there
are now zero fees when it comes to
buying or selling bitcoin on binance
which is a game changer and on top of
that they've always had some of the
lowest transaction fees around with
bonus you can trace 600 different
cryptos anywhere anytime and 90 million
users are already taking advantage of it
if you've always wanted to get into
crypto but you're nervous about getting
started binance is the perfect solution
because binance is offering new users
outside of the us up to 600 in bonus
rewards just for signing up and going to
the task center as you complete each
task you'll get some free money for
example you get a five dollar cashback
if you make a first time deposit of more
than a hundred dollars within the first
five days and more up to six hundred
dollars just for trading on binance so
to start taking advantage of the zero
fee bitcoin trading u.s residents can
sign up at binance.us and new users from
outside the us can get up to 600 and
sign up rewards if you use my link below
so pause the video right now and click
on the link below thanks to finance for
sponsoring this video
today johnson johnson is the world's
most valuable and admired pharmaceutical
company it's worth nearly half a
trillion dollars that's more than the
entire gdp of the united arab emirates
but beneath all that success and your oh
so perfect reputation lies a dark
history
johnson johnson was started by a guy
named robert wood johnson and his two
brothers all the way back in 1886.
robert had been working as a
pharmaceutical apprentice when he got
the idea to start selling ready-to-use
surgical dressings aka band-aids the
johnson brothers business took off and
before long they were making and selling
almost everything you could find in an
1800s first aid kit but let's be honest
even though selling band-aids and
bandages is good business it's just not
big enough
obviously the johnson brothers had a
talent for inventing and selling medical
products but what about expanding your
market beyond pharmacies and doctors
what if you could appeal to a wider
audience what if you could sell to
babies obviously not actual babies you'd
be selling to their parents but you get
the idea
think about it parents would do anything
for their precious babies
if you could make a product and convince
parents that their babies can't live
without this product you would be
sitting on a gold mine
and that's where johnson and johnson
baby powder came in your miracle
invention most parents today will tell
you diaper rash can be a real nightmare
it leaves kids screaming and crying all
day and the problem wasn't much
different back in the 1800s when babies
still had to wear rough diapers made of
cloth so you came up with a simple
solution a smooth soft powder that would
absorb moisture and stop diapers from
scratching baby's skin
simple but effective
and it was a near instant hit
no one could believe such an annoying
worrying part of looking after a baby
could be solved by a little white powder
and it wasn't long before even adults
started using this new baby powder to
keep themselves dry and comfy but that
wasn't all
building off that success instead of
just sticking to baby powder you created
an entire line of baby products to make
parents lives easier and soon you were
raking in millions expanding into big
time pharmaceuticals medicine
manufacturing and making a name for
yourself all over america all thanks to
baby powder
now if you're wondering why baby powder
was so integral to your success just
take a look at johnson and johnson's
marketing tactics
like most major companies today you
realized early on that appealing to
logic and reason makes good money but
appealing to emotions makes millions
instead of targeting the world with
success stories on how great your
band-aids were how many people love your
baby powder you switched it up and
appealed to people's feelings
you used your baby powder brand to turn
your image into a family-friendly
company the kind of company that has
families and their best interests at
heart the kind that would give new
parents that warm and fuzzy feeling
knowing they were using only the best
products on their infants
your line of baby products became your
emotional selling point the thing you
could point to and say look how much we
care
and it worked whether you were selling
tylenol or cough syrup your reputation
as a family company made you america's
first choice
people couldn't help but fall for the
idea of a company that really cared
about its customers and that blind trust
gave you all the leverage to take
advantage of your loyal customers in
almost any way you liked that was until
2010 happened
[Music]
2010 was a really really bad year for
johnson and johnson no seriously in the
history of multinational corporations i
don't think anyone had a year that
sucked quite as much
first you had to recall 40 types of kids
medicines for being contaminated or
using the wrong ingredients then you had
to recall nearly half a million boxes of
contact lenses after customers
experienced extreme pain while wearing
them less than a week after that you
recalled all your supply of antacids
because people had found pieces of wood
and metal in the tablets and to make
matters worse your line of hip
replacements ended up shedding dangerous
metal debris in the bodies of the people
who used them
but none of this nothing could top the
risperdahl marketing scandal the cherry
on the cake for a really really terrible
year you see risperdal was one of your
best selling medications it's an
antipsychotic drug prescribed to treat
people with schizophrenia but like so
many pharma companies before you people
with schizophrenia just didn't seem like
a big enough market to target
but how do i make money off depressed
people only around 2.8 million people in
america have schizophrenia but nearly 6
million people in america have dementia
or alzheimer's
two diseases you thought risperdal could
be pretty good for if you could just get
all the old people with dementia onto
your drug you'd triple your customer
base
and since dementia patients don't
exactly have the power to decide what
medication they want to take
you had the perfect way in
omnicare
the biggest company supplying medicine
to nursing homes in the us
if you could get omnicare pharmacists
and doctors to swap out their patients
regular dementia medication for
risperdal you would be golden
so even though the fda had warned you
that risperdal could be deadly to
elderly patients you still offered
omnicare everything from sponsorship
payments grants and even actual profit
sharing and risperdal to make your plan
a reality
basically you bribed omnicare to give
their patients your drug instead of the
medicine they were supposed to get by
the way all of this is super illegal in
the five years that omnicare marketed
your drug the revenue you made through
them almost tripled from 100 million
dollars to over 280 million dollars just
as you had planned that's a lot of money
but even that wasn't enough why stop
with old people whispered all was doing
so well why not start marketing it to
parents with mentally ill kids too
so you went to one of the best child
psychiatrists you could find and offered
him the deal of a lifetime you would
finance a research center specifically
for him
if he could find a way to prove that
risperdal could be used to treat bipolar
disorder in kids
around 3 percent of all kids and teens
have some kind of bipolar disorder if
your new psychiatrist friend could make
it seem like risperdal worked for them
that would be another 2 million
customers to exploit
and sure risperdal could cause
humiliating side effects for teens but
who cared you'd be making even more
money
no one knows where you would have
stopped with the bribes if you hadn't
been caught
but in 2010 your little kickback program
was blown wide open
reports revealed that j and j had paid
tens of millions of dollars to make
risperdal omnicare's number one best
seller
people were appalled but as always the
shock and horror only lasted a few days
and sure you got fined a couple of times
and even had to settle a couple of
lawsuits but unlike the sackler family
from purdue pharma who were partly
responsible for america's opioid crisis
there wasn't any naming or shaming
people just seemed to forget
and eventually the articles and news
stories went away too
jay and jay survived
in the three years between 1972 and 1975
johnson and johnson baby powder tested
positive for asbestos three separate
times
but instead of warning the fda changing
your product recipe or even just
ordering more tests to figure out how
bad the contamination was you decided to
do nothing
you see back in the 1970s you were at
your peak johnson's baby powders made me
feel soft fresh and loved everyone loved
johnson and johnson if you gave them bad
news about one of your products now your
business would be doomed
so you did the only logical thing
you labeled the researchers who found
the asbestos antagonistic personalities
and told everyone they were leading an
attack on talc the core ingredient in
your baby powder
you painted them to be the bad guys
there was no way you were going to stop
producing one of your best-selling
products and admit you made a mistake
now plus how bad could a little asbestos
really be
this is darlene coker in the 1990s she
was diagnosed with a very rare type of
cancer
the type of cancer most commonly
diagnosed in minors who inhaled asbestos
dust
but where had darlene come into contact
with asbestos she never worked in any
factories or mines and she lived in a
small town in eastern texas
but here's the thing
every day darlene coker would use
johnson and johnson baby powder
as a massage therapist johnson and
johnson baby powder helped her stay
fresh and comfortable during her long
work day but according to darlene it
also poisoned her
in pain and fighting for every breath
she took darlene sued johnson and
johnson in 1999
unsurprisingly jay and jay denied
everything
your baby powder was asbestos free there
was no way you were responsible for her
cancer and when darlene's lawyers asked
to see proof you used your money and
power to block them from ever actually
seeing the talc test results for your
baby powder
it was one woman versus a massive
multinational corporation
she had lost before the lawsuit even
started
darlene coker died of cancer 10 years
after her failed lawsuit she was lucky
most other people with her type of
cancer don't even make it a year
but none of that mattered to you
it would take another 20 years after
darlene's lawsuit for hundreds of cancer
patients to finally get the proof they
needed to hold you accountable
the evidence shows you knew about the
asbestos in your baby powder for 50
years and did nothing about it and even
then the best you could offer was to
stop selling your baby powder in america
and canada but the rest of the world
that's still fair game out of sight out
of mind right
and when other people with cancer tried
to take you to court well you had one
more trick up your sleeve you used a law
in texas to create a new company dump
all your baby powder lawsuits and
asbestos liabilities into the new
company and have it file for bankruptcy
just a few weeks later
basically obliterating 38 000 people's
chance to hold you accountable for your
lies
johnson and johnson may have managed to
escape getting labeled as an evil
company but not every profit hungry
multinational corporation can do the
same and no one knows that better than
monsanto arguably one of america's most
hated companies that's right up there
with purdue
just like johnson and johnson monsanto
started out all innocent and meant well
but it quickly turned into one of
america's most dangerous companies today
it pretty much owns the entire world's
food supply but it had to do some pretty
horrifying things to get to that point
how bad did it get on monsanto's rise to
the top so bad that if we went into the
details here the video would get
demonetized faster than you can say
agent orange
but obviously we're not going to keep a
juicy eye opening documentary like that
away from you just because youtube won't
like it so instead of posting it in
public we released it as a
feature-length private documentary
that's only available to members of this
channel
this documentary goes into every last
detail of monsanto's bloodlust for money
and so far channel members have been
loving it
and all you have to do to access the
documentary right now as well as all our
other private videos on topics like mk
ultra the cia's mind control program cia
black sites the real story behind every
gepstein and a lot more is to click that
join button below
you'll be learning the kind of stuff
they'll never teach you in university
for just five dollars a month and in a
way that's way more entertaining than
university lectures
plus there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships so if you join
and don't think it's worth it email us
within your first month of joining and
we will personally refund you for your
first month after your first month there
is no refund so scroll down and hit that
join button now
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video and if you're new here my name is
jake and this is one of the biggest
channels on youtube for documentaries on
money power war and crime so if you
enjoyed this one click the subscribe
button below you can always dislike
unsubscribe and leave me your best hate
comments whenever you want if you want
shorter versions of these videos you can
follow me on facebook but that's going
to wrap it up stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
you